[Musik]
ja
falls ihr euch fragt warum ich mit allen
möglichen gepäck in der gondel sitzen
bleibt bestehen einfach so ausgesucht
dass ich auf der spitze von berg
befindet
ich bin gespannt liter räder vorne schon
wieder tecdoc
hat eigentlich schon
ein sprecher
sogar die tatsache dass aus dem zoll
schwer
vor allem ihr gleich zu sternen gänge
menü nicht mehr cash
pooling kling
[Musik]
dies hier der einzige ort wo du mit paid
messungen ganz mcdonald's ziel einfach
aus staten zahn verloren
[Musik]
der nächste gang hier ist jetzt ein
online dass es irgendwie irgendwas aus
japan
ist sehr
interessante kunst die hier steht es
gibt nichts nerviges solche wasser hin
wo man drauf drückt das wasser ist nicht
nur so
drei sekunden solche teile sollten
einfach verbannt werden ich hab mich
grad so erschrocken als ich um die ecke
gelaufen grabmal aus dem notausgang aus
dem hotel rausgegangen weil man weiß
halt einfach nicht so richtig raus kommt
weil das das ganze gebäude ist
ich zeige euch gleich auch mal das
zimmer die sache ist dass wir angekommen
sind werden was gegessen wir haben
keinen mittagsschlaf gemacht weil wir
die ganze zeit irgendwie letzten tage
nur unterwegs sind und jetzt stehe ich
hier gerade mitten auf der piste
das ist geisteskrank
es ist auch geisteskrankheiten
song hollywood film wo irgendwie planung
das wenn es ein anderer planet wäre oder
sohn alles andere so schwarz ist der
weltraum befinden uns auf
2336 metern höhe und es wäre einfach nur
geisteskrank herunterzufahren also ich
glaube alle leute die gerne skifahren
wissen gerade wie heftig das wäre vor
allem wenn das bedeutet aber
madame ist galt deswegen in das hotel zu
machen
ich spielte mit lasso lange auf ein
bisschen draußen
[Musik]
30 minuten später freunde hätten hat
auch in straß das hotel ist unfassbar
krass geil euren alles aus holz zu gehen
ich schlafe ich zeige euch das hier
morgen mal vernünftig
hallo
hier vorne befindet sich unser an
kleidet die uns direkt weiter bringt die
gäste drei klassen sind
allerdings vom eingang des spiels nicht
untergehen die anteile sondern in
richtung sind eine ahnung hier vorne
haben wir einen atemberaubenden ausblick
über das ist in meinem gesicht und an
ahnung wie vor befindet sich daran dass
da warst du möchtest und boden befindet
sich das war's da badezimmer mit einer
dusche die
verwahrung denn duschen ist kann man es
wichtig einen wundervollen ausblick über
das zillertal genießen meine lieben
freunde schauen lassen nimmt ja habe
dann einen riesigen spiegel die herren
beiden lassen nennt der spiegel
reflektiert das wundervolle tageslicht
und diesen grellen schnee der wenn wir
dieses gefühl auch vermittelt dass er
einfach das ganze zimmer erhält
wiederaufnahmen was die langen lassen
keine ahnung allerdings haben wir hier
neben dann auch ungemein das
unternehmen befindet sich das unseren
listen
und wenn man die infrarotkabine dann
allerdings verletzt sehen wir schon hier
unseren badewanne
wenn man allerdings nicht warten möchte
kann man sich auch einfach ganz entstand
auf das sofa verlieren und den ausblick
über das senat angewiesen weil er die
freunde werden müsste wenn wir sind
minibar ist natürlich direkt zugänglich
vom wunderschönen großen bett warum hast
du meinen klassen und keine ahnung zu
guter letzt genießt man dann natürlich
auch vom bett den wunderschönen ausblick
über das
die leute erstmal real-tor das hotel ist
einfach nur über krass das ist total
exklusiv weil die haben nur sechs zimmer
oder so allerdings kennt ihr peyton
irgendwie wählen deswegen durften jetzt
hier hin und ich bin dabei immer spaß
aber erst mal frühstücken wahrscheinlich
so heißt es 39 in diesem falle hier
schon am skifahren und gerade
aufgestanden frühstücken
[Musik]
actimel aktiviert abwehrkräfte die
bilder die wir gestern einfach lustig
gemacht haben stehen hier elf
ausgeschriebene 2700 euro 3000 euro
es sieht einfach aus wie ein kölner
klubs auf toilette dusche
das jetzt einfach die wildeste toilette
der welt in wenn man hier vorne rein
geht und hier am scheißen ist kann man
einfach hier rauskommen und sieht die
ganzen werke und hier unten sogar leute
ski fahren wir fahren jetzt nach ich
frage mich aber ehrlich gesagt wir
diesen berg wieder runterkommen wollen
alles klar
ist auf jeden fall entspannt
ich habe mich ja gerade nur eine szene
eingeblendet wie wir mal kurz um eine
kurve rumgefahren sind auf diesen
schneemobil weil der typ mit 70 km
gebildet ist ich hoffe nicht fehlen ich
habe noch ein handy-video wäre ich
gerade
ja von
beeten ist sie auf jeden fall gerade am
tanken und wir fahren jetzt wohin
der ort heißt einfach raus mein
kleidungsstil ist heute nicht sonderlich
wie sehr er wollte einfach mal einem
dampfbad rumfahren münchen sind jetzt
hier in münchen in der türkenstraße
angekommen hier sind tolle läden um die
frau dachte bestimmt ich filme sie also
ich habe das gesehen hat sich verstecken
kann ihn jetzt auf jeden fall eine pid
seiten oder nur denn keine ahnung als
münchen und jetzt verlassen in münchen
auch schon wieder denn wir waren gerade
noch kurz pizza essen was ich vergessen
zu filmstar wir sehen uns immer nach dem
jahreswechsel gemacht und die verzeiht
ungelogen zehn minuten und wir wurden
schon anrufe von emir von immun wir
angehupt was deine was sagst du dazu
holen die brauchen wir gleich
krankenwagen
wieder mannheim angekommen und haben nur
in gekochter
abbruch fokussiere mich was ist ja
quatsch
[Musik]